league players have been speedrunning
how fast they can kill the dragon after
its first spawn so let me ask you how
fast do you think the brand new world
record is 30 seconds 10 seconds 5
Seconds not even close
all right while some players are out
there crushing records you can go out
there and crush it in style with our
brand new line of merch we've got all
kinds of stuff on there my favorite is
the touchgrass hoodie it just looks
really fresh not gonna lie follow the
link in the description to check it out
for yourself alright so for as long as
the dragon has existed in League of
Legends in some form people have been
trying to see how fast they can kill it
now obviously with enough time items and
stacking a lot of Champions in League
can kill epic monsters almost instantly
for example here's a clip of orengar
instantly blowing up Baron with a single
queue it looks cool but the point is a
lot of Champions can do things like this
if they get fed enough what's more
impressive is killing something quickly
as soon as it spawns in a real game
against other players the dragon first
spawns in a game of League at five
minutes and so for many years players
have been seeing how quickly they can
kill it at that exact moment and at the
five minute Mark your Champion isn't
usually that strong you'll usually be
about level four maybe you have around
30 he asked maybe you've backed and
picked up an item five average players
in a normal game like that would
struggle to kill the dragon particularly
quickly on spawn but if you build your
entire team comp around that goal things
can get a lot quicker last Saturday
Reddit user by shot X posted to the
league subreddit with a clip that
claimed to show the world's fastest ever
season 13 Dragon kill on spawn
and mate
[Music]
yeah that was a real blink and you miss
it moment about 1.6 seconds this
generated a lot of buzz in the league
community and with all that attention
contenders came and pretty soon that
group had been knocked off their top
spot they quickly regrouped though and
less than 24 hours after their first
record they came back to smash the
record once again bringing it down to an
astonishing
0.485 seconds so how do they do it well
first let's talk about the obvious thing
here they all took Smite this allowed
them to instantly do a combined 3000
damage to the dragon then you've got
nunu's consumability which is going to
do at least 400 true damage a fully
charged Scion q and W and Udi's
empowered q but if you watch the clip
closely you'll also see the activated
nine gin traps they'd stacked on the
dragon's spawn spot and used syndra to
fling the Scuttle crab onto the Trap so
that they'd already be exploding the
moment the dragon landed and this was a
clever attack me that was immediately
praised by the community in the comments
then there's also the fact that this was
a chem Tech Drake which has about 700 HP
less than the other dragons so yeah
everything just really fell into place
for this one but as amazing as that
attempt was it didn't last for long a
YouTube channel called hextech lab came
along and snatched that number one spot
away from them and so before we look at
the brand new world record I want to
remind you guys that all of these
attempts are done in genuine games
against real people that's the only way
they will appear on the leaderboard so
not only do you have to get all these
timings down to the absolute millisecond
the enemy team might just ruin the whole
thing anyway like if they took the
Scuttle crab that would just ruin the
whole gin trap element of the attempt
Bear all that in mind when you watch the
new world record
[Music]
thank you
0.478 seconds the new world record for
killing dragon on spawn insane
especially when you learn that it took
these guys around five hours to get this
record and there's only a one in six
chance of getting the required chemtech
Drake spawn to pull this thing off they
also use a couple of different Champs
compared to the previous attempts that
we've taken a look at such as volley
with his e or Varys with his q but it
seems to me like the syndra Scuttle crab
gin trap combo is the main damage dealer
here with maybe a little bit of Scion on
the side but the fact that two quite
different comms was so close to each
other in time suggested me that almost
unbelievably there may still be room for
improvement here some people have
suggested getting a cho'gath on your
team to level six so that he can alt the
dragon I saw someone else suggest you
get five more friends to cue snipe your
group and then you just 10 man Dragon I
think there's definitely room to
experiment if you think you can beat
this league of graphs has a records page
that tracks a whole bunch of different
records in the game from most kills
deaths or assists to the more outlandish
ones like the dragon killing record and
if you do want to have a go at making it
to the top of one of those lists they
actually reset every season little tip
for you there that simple Reddit video
from the weekend kick-started a frenzy
of dragon kill speed running attempts
now for some people they might find the
concept of speedrunning in League of
Legends a little bit strange but there
is actually a small but dedicated
community of people who do this kind of
stuff speedrun.com has its own category
for League of Legends which tracks
current and past season records for
things like the fastest Scuttle crab
kill fastest to 100 CS or my personal
favorite fastest to lose a bot game
you've got this you've got this I
believe in you box let's go baby you
guys are fine you got 20 25 30 seconds
to hit the Nexus just keep ending
nobody's gonna stop you Seventh Place
let's go Seventh Place Seventh Place
let's go Seventh Place let's go
seventh in the world yeah baby or
there's the famous vandral video from
two years ago where he broke the record
for the fastest death in a ranked game
ever by running it down with ramus and
dying
21.446 seconds into the game that's less
than seven seconds after the barrier
came down look some games are better for
Speed running than others I don't think
we're gonna see League speed running
streams get more popular than Minecraft
ones for example but these kind of
things are still cool to see within
League the game has been out for well
over a decade at this point and for a
lot of players it's fun to see people
Theory crafting like this and pushing
the game to its absolute limit and like
speedrunning in a lot of other games out
there sometimes you don't take on the
challenge because it makes sense or
because there's thousands of other
people competing sometimes you speedrun
just because you can
I'm looking at the different categories
on speedrun.com and League of Legends
there's fastest to 100 CS there's
fastest to build a trinity Force fastest
to lose I think I'm on there I am on
there there I am number six fastest ever
loss in a game